for more on how the midterms might
unfold let's bring in Anthony silvonto
with our newest Battleground tracker
poll Anthony good morning how's it
looking all right so we find after
talking to voters across all these
districts put it in the model
Republicans at 228 seats that's a slight
majority there but Ed was talking about
turnout let me show you specifically why
that's so important because we can run
some scenarios off of this now for
Democrats if they get bigger turnout if
they get specifically more turnout among
younger voters they have a chance see
this little bit of a swing back here
okay to maybe hold the house by a seat
or two you see it gets to about even
that's why it's so important for them
but Republicans have been the ones
telling us they're more motivated
they're more enthusiastic if I put that
in the model watch that in the middle it
gets a little bit of a bigger majority
for Republicans they go up to 238 should
that happen that's the range of
possibilities so best case scenario for
Democrats then is is even if young
people turn out if Republicans turn out
they've got a pretty commanding lead
there what's motivating voters here in
the final days well let me show you this
the party's closing arguments are really
between democracy and economy the
Democrats arguing there's threats to
democracy the Republicans saying focus
on the economy because folks think it's
it's bad so look at this we ask people
what concerns you more having a
functioning democracy having a strong
economy and it's pretty split yeah but
look at the vote splits on this Tony
when you see the folks who prioritize
functioning democracy they're voting for
Democrats that's their message folks who
prioritize a strong economy they're
voting Republican that's theirs yeah
although of course we would hope and you
didn't give them the choice but everyone
wants both everybody wants both it's a
question of priorities because look
that's ultimately what a vote is right
you got to make a choice and this is
what the parties are saying each side
has to prioritize all right Anthony
Savant thank you very much